okay people joining this livestream this
is I don't know how many designers have
done today maybe it's five or six um
this is one about natural language
processing and text cases so which
version should I be in head branch build
or prototype build or something else
how do I find out is that a sign that
it's broken or is that a sign with it so
it's an empty that says it seems to work
it okay so if I say Wikipedia data of
cat and then I say what would i if I
then say text cases of that comma
country for example but I expect that to
work okay
now what does this mean yeah this a
change now there are three kinds of
process bar because there are three kind
of long processes so instead of
processing is telling like the tactic
entities things like this
that's rather spectacular by the way
what is it that except the u.s is kind
of weird here because there is us in the
later part of that list mm-hmm we should
put them together right that's really
odd okay but can we see drunk and you
see can you send through some screen
caps of your progress indicators yes
where should I send it just send it to
my email
okay guide page what is it called text
content types
does it look like a latest version I
just pulled this to go okay so we
decided to separate into interpretable
elements it's everything that is
interpreted but not an entity then we
have the list of entity that are
separated the same way as interpreter
does you should yeah
then there is I don't know how to format
this because here we don't have links
for the all this stuff but we could link
to the Ling programming language
classifier for example which lists all
these entities okay
well this is definitely an improvement
as a page um okay um so okay [ __ ]
closing functions such as
support many
allow text
well allowed many different kinds of
types of
tend to be identified and text um some
of these types of content some of these
while others relate to semantic
interpretation something like that okay
let's look at how this is set up okay I
think these should come much higher up
let's take a look here I would recommend
that we start with these constituents
and parts of speech okay okay yeah they
are small as well so it's easy to find
the rest but hard to find them I agree
okay let's call them structural
components if you don't mind or it's
that unreasonable and is that bad
technical terminology we already called
them structural something structural
choice in the past actually in the
condition we said true structural choice
don't know what strict I mean we just
say possible choices are and them say
structural choices are okay okay
structural elements
why don't we have text if we have num um
yeah but the way these are like is
related to exotic characters inside the
text cream and Jane you you give some
code something and you want to grab all
the text which would mean all the
commands so I don't know
I got a depends your fear of text really
yeah it's not for non text is doing it's
not going to work also and you could
have natural language text somewhere
okay here let's move those guys down we
can just say
you
you
let's just list these on one line here
punctuation weight spacing emoticon
because it's really clear up there all
ha
you
and I assume white-spaces capitalized
the semi in other places I think so
let's check
yeah there's actually a single white
space okay Wyatt is loose in this wacky
order isn't it noun-verb I mean isn't
that let's not put an alphabetical order
that's not helping anybody okay let's
try and put in an order that actually
makes some sense
but are not ordinary letter like text
okay now let me try and pull these out
of here noun-verb I think this is kind
of like a canonical order isn't it I
mean now in verb adjective adverb
there is a part of speech of page where
there's a list
there's no how to complete list oh are
you serious
what happened to that and now I'm very
chatty Vadra
you're right proposition determiner what
I'm sorry what where is that what
happened to the parts of speech parts of
speech this is part of speech what the
heck why isn't that coming up correctly
I'm saying gate function page
anything that's names it's named parts
of speech the function is called
speechless yeah I am wrong but it I see
it in documentation bill so if it is
excised I shouldn't be seeing it unless
it was excised in version 12 something
is wrong here something is wrong you
should check into this because I'm
seeing part of speech no I don't know it
worked
yeah it wasn't I've probably renamed it
to school parts of speech before so it's
all documentation
anyway the order is a noun verb
adjective adverb preposition conjunction
pronoun with a minor intersection and
then we you could obscure after is
really pronoun is
far down okay preposition
I guess not every language
has pronouns preposition conjunction
then canal pronoun
the termination
okay now let's have a separate line that
starts out for this next case okay so
let's go
what's particle
you
I am that's the expecting drama I think
it's like in Greek I know it's the words
like death in an ancient Greek I'm sorry
I got another learn grammar of any
modern language okay let's list here
because they're very important like
proper noun um her someone our live
stream is suggesting a different order
I'm not sure about that I think
noun-verb
I mean nouns and verbs are the most
common I understand that noun goes with
pronoun adjective goes but then noun
pronoun adjective will go together I
agree
I think this is the the order of cominis
of those types of words I mean if we
look at in English I bet we'd find that
the number of fat I'm just going to
determine this because I'm curious um
apparently particle-like in the phrase
in the sentence many of the books off is
a particle which please me
you
I mean though that means it's an obscure
so if I say parts of speech of all
what's it going to say
part of speech of of preposition which
is what I thought it was so what does it
mean that it's a particle the Wikipedia
said in English particle is a somewhat
nebulous term for a variety of small
words that not conveniently fit into
other classes of words okay so look at
this interesting thing so well it's
interesting the number of adjectives hmm
are there any other can you find lists
of parts of speech somewhere and see
what ordering they have
and to me from you know random languages
I've learned this would be the order I
would pick but I don't know whether
that's some
okay so down here a very important one
is proper noun right and I think that
might even be a line listing because I
think that's something people want all
the time do you agree I mean a separate
line for proper noun okay yeah yes
whether in Wikipedia it's about the same
except that pronoun is just after adverb
that's where I were to put it and they
don't even oh yeah and and determiner is
after interjection and let's Wikipedia
determine is the last one or transition
I have no opinion about that what do we
say just as if I say thee does that say
determiner here yeah which is also
called article that's right so they
always used to be called as article I
don't know why the heck they will rename
to termers and it's like people say you
know things like add position instead of
preposition and things back in the day
they always used to be called articles
and I'm going to leave them in that
order because I don't like having them
offer interjections I think and
ejections of fake words all right so we
move pronoun here
you
you
how did I mess this up sorry Sushma can
you check this page
incidentally obviously part of speech
should point to text cases and those
other things right
um
probably even the very first thing here
should be extra well text structure and
then text cases probably because that's
what
- dude if you want to pick out parts of
speech okay I proper noun so how do we
define proper noun what does it do for
us it's a noun which is not going now I
understand um so it's the one okay
understand for pasta right it's a proper
noun referring to a specific thing
typically referring to a specific thing
I don't know that's a great definition
of proper noun but it can be it can be a
brown the food for example right look
typically typically beginning with the
capital letter but okay New York's that
b12 / now to rewrite what do we do for
that
for the moment we separate but they can
show this kind of things
I don't believe parts of speech should
be referred to by a phrases I think we
should call these phrase types oh yeah
definitely
I mean it's grammatical unit at the
phrase level so that was fishing wrong
okay so let's let's look here
okay so we got proper noun here so the
next thing that I think is important is
all these WH things I said WH pronoun
there why don't we have a general WH
word who what when where why what is who
anyway it's a pronoun yeah wow that's a
conjunction that's fine but but um which
and it can be both that's good to over
situation okay which ones are adverbs
why are we calling these question words
is the best
Asian of three-panel fake a bench back
of speech taking so we need Sun dressing
question alright you can put these in
none questions sometimes L saw ya
someone on our livestream is asking
about transitive verbs and so on yeah
we'd love to do that let's give us a
chance we've already got a hundred
different types of things we're tagging
right now um okay well okay so one of
the things we're gonna have is um okay
so pronoun I'll say question like words
who when who why hey now some of these
other ones what does possessive modifier
that's an apostrophe s okay so now we
have the various fragment words um which
I think we can just list
yeah somebody's complaining there for
more categories this isn't a
classification from ancient times yeah
um oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah we'd love to be able to
train the system on other stuff
what is limiting what we were able to
train on here though it's just about
collecting data I mean it may be up
there somewhere so we haven't been
looking much in improving this part okay
I mean a little person live stream have
suggestions for datasets we'd be
thrilled I mean we things like penn
treebank and so on we've used all the
standard things yes we used yeah we use
these things for power speech but I
don't know if it's murder priorities I
don't know I don't think it is I don't
think this is the priority I think the
priority is more um actual entities of
various kinds exactly that's what we
worked on um okay here um okay so let's
look
we've got here we've got foreign word I
think we need to define that punctuation
numeral it's fairly obvious what that is
possessive modifier what a mess okay
I think possessive modifier arguably
goes there um the mysterious particle
what is a symbol something like a
section starter he's taking an equation
okay well is that a single symbol or is
that something else okay but what do you
think like an X that just sits out there
a symbol yeah
I mean arguably every one of these these
things are going to need their own
separate documentation pages these are
these are ultimately these will be
identification types right yeah but
there are entities with all this stuff
what do you mean that we have an entity
type called a grammatical units and you
know all of these are entities in this
set then you know what we should link
these to the grammatical unit entity
page for now do you understand you know
the problem is okay link I wanna put a
link but we have to list the
[Music]
string because from the government pays
you don't have the strings I understand
that although those are the canonical
names of the grammatical entity and I
mean if I say you're saying entity and I
say grammatical unit comma symbol for
example okay what are the properties of
that you know hmm and probably knowing
will be that's pretty impoverished let's
ask the curation team to put some
examples to have another property to be
examples
or even while we just listing what they
are in English why isn't one property of
symbol or one of these other ones like
numeral well a tree numeral will be kind
of crazy because there's an infinite
number of them probably I'm going to
suggest that the Croatian team adds
examples to these that makes sense to
suggest it if they complain um okay okay
phrase types oh my gosh this is a huge
can of worms again um removed for
example things like numeral because we
already have number well I don't know
where the numeral is the same as number
second third you know that would be
computing and that that's a numeral
could be an ordinal or cardinal number
good again there's an infinite amount of
fine graining which could be used here
but I just don't think this is not what
people mostly want here um okay so in
phrase types let's just go through these
because we've got you know we've got the
basic things wherever they are which is
noun phrase and then let's get on to
entity types because those are the
really the things that we're really
going to be concerned about um okay so
we've got noun phrase let's we're gonna
um let's follow
verb phrase
you
then we have got
adjectives an adverb phrase
you
oh boy
some of these other ones conjunction
phrase
prepositional phrase a quantifier phrase
what a mess that goes with numerals um
language is such a mess
okay I mean what's interesting is how
constant all of these structures are
across so many human languages
to me that's interesting okay
so now here somewhat brizola we have a
wh noun phrase
see that's a which animal escaped from
the zoo for example I think right you
could try it takes cases of which animal
escaped from the zoo holding it straight
okay
you
right sure what I want to do is text
contents of which animal I'm naturally
phrase are there by default in text
contents not encouraging let's do text
structure here is text content by
default it will search for entities
without the path of speech stuff yes I'm
right which animal by the way text
structure obviously should point back to
text cases let's just do that that isn't
already the case probably that's already
yes it does it probably also should
point actually before it even gets oh no
it should it point to text contents yes
chuckling morgue the contents type thing
because it gives everything so yeah even
before
okay all right okay noun phrase
um
okay so then let's go through the
sequence we did before pronoun why isn't
there a pronoun phrase why isn't there a
a wh pronoun phrase oh because it isn't
a phrase in English but I bet it can be
in other languages like oh no no it
can't be a pronoun because it would be a
pronoun as is just a small I think
you
I mean the only thing we're really
trying to do here is to make it so that
people can have a hope of finding what
they're looking for in these lists um
okay now
okay these next few things
I mean arguably some of the stuff yeah I
think we do have to have the parts of
speech and so on at the top because then
we're going to get to these
interpretable elements as you're calling
them which are much more of the meat of
what's going on and then to the and then
to the entities types okay so what is a
fragment do you know
mmm it's a piece of sentence is related
what is sentence the sentence is a hole
okay so there's a line here which has if
you write an incomplete sentence and
take structure for example is it
fragments or oh yes it does so that
would be right that goes along with
these
now what's list marker it's when you a
memory stuff like one two three blitz
okay what is not a constituent
parenthetical goes on these I think now
why isn't a quotation along with like a
parenthetical why is it why is a
quotation different from a parenthetical
why is that a different type of thing
how come we've got sentence twice if
sentence twice it's a bit on purpose
because it's not a program right to
repeat stuff into several categories
that's not a huge problem but it's not
relevant if it isn't you know if we if
we don't really need it here I would
take it out but quotation seems much
more like it goes down here don't you
think there's a method behind is very
different but well the only issue is
that the containing stuff goes these
structural elements yeah when you say
containing don't we want to mention the
containing stuff here it's only for what
for sentence paragraph and line I said
oh no does it work with a quotation or
it does not make sense
I don't put everything okay so I guess
why do we Scottish it would make sense
well maybe we should put it right at the
top containing now is there any other
thing which applies to everything is
there any other wrapper
I'll tell it seems yeah we've got
alternatives containing verb at him
what's that
about him which verbatim well yeah
verbatim you to do really a string
carries we're using the term verbatim I
think so it's not documented because
actually it's just doing a string hazing
in this case it's our way in but you
could do you know quit containing
quotation verbatim I guess okay strings
to match for basically yeah exactly
okay so then we've got alternatives and
except presumably right except we don't
have really an end all so if you want to
put constraints what kind of constraints
what end I don't know what stake you
weren't a fan in like what alternative
is for all but we don't have a pattern
like this like I want to all the city
that have a name of a code or I don't
know what better way to yes I understand
that require both that's an interesting
question I mean that kind of pattern
intersection thing we have considered
for the pattern matcher so Shamar I
think that's another ILD topic the
pattern intersection case the fact that
it hasn't been needed in thirty years is
because most patterns don't these kinds
of sort of fake patterns are much more
likely to need that than a genuine
structural pattern okay so you can do it
with two accepts Wow yes so you can okay
alternatives um
let's see types
alternative types or types some
um
allow multiple types
um
types that can up that must appear
within other types eg
No
you
let's see
define containers eg sentences for
matches
you
allow multiple types to match
instrumental types
you
you
that okay got a better idea
okay so now here we have I think noun
phrase head comes first
produced relative clause oh boy that's
what that say
now those are things actually these
should be in a separate list hi what a
mess
you
okay Klaus
I think reduced relative clause and
unlike coordinated
do you know what any of these are
it's very what is not a constituent
well why don't you go find out what it
is and then we'll discuss it okay now in
phrase head quantifier a phrase I'm not
sure what that is exactly
okay all right okay let's keep going
though
okay I don't really like the term
interpretable elements but what should
we call these tonight see everything
that is as an interpreter but not an
entity actually tutorial is never an
interpreter so what exactly that okay um
write something well the interpreter
won't return an entity but something
else which quantities or addresses no
nothing you know string sort of you know
infeed said type thing you know I know
it's the infinite set case as opposed to
the fixed set of entities um which I
guess you can separate in adversity then
Numerical stuff
all right let's do this um what are
those what are those cells put up what
type of those cells and do you know if
you're doing this correctly in Sushma I
think you need to
no that's a completely wrong level there
it's more water yeah that's a completely
wrong level so Sushma you can have to
talk to Brian about what yeah and also
are the guide pages that are
experimental because this one shows that
it's experimental I think there are okay
I can check that I'm not certain
okay so
these seem like the wrong
you
yeah we've got some suggestions on our
livestream we have pluralize we can
change em number we don't have a way to
change tensors yet we are working on the
curation of inflections been doing that
for about a year um and that's slowly
chugging along although I have to say
that the usage of these very grammatical
things has not been that great um it's
just no it's not how we do natural
language understanding and it doesn't
seem to be okay anyway so this is um so
here we've got okay what is this what is
that is that a that's is that sort of
subsection heading look I think this is
a total mess this this I think you've
got completely the wrong that's a
subsection maybe this is a subsection
you were right okay
so then um
okay quantitative
you
quantitative elements let's say
you
and I'm gonna squiggle color into that
um color textually described color right
yes does it do light blue it should
okay thanks that section is um
time and place
you
you
and third piece here
you
identification elements
you
they may be already separating
interpreter now in such form mistake
okay so here I can't imagine my twitter
handle needs to be separated out
it is that it's not documented because
there is no interpreter types Twitter
endure phone
all right let's leave it like this this
is okay I think it's not great and maybe
as we change it okay you can't say that
you can't put text in here okay that's
okay okay okay so but the content is
important is that it's not just for this
specific set it's not just the type that
you can inquiry can also query a
specific element of this type I can look
for all the cities but you can also look
at rest America okay well so then let's
let's do this let's say entity okay um
match a specific entity eg and now I'm
going to do control equals which of
course doesn't work in here it cannot
insert a free-form thing at that
location of the control equals New York
that probably needs
be rendered nicely make sense that's
that's what you meant by this right
yes but also that the types that we list
to miss you post these types I'm sorry
it only support the types that are
listed below
so we have this one wouldn't sell
antitype or whatever and you can only
ask entities belonging to these types
okay
match a specific entity I think this is
okay I think it's okay we can explain
that somewhere in text cases yeah
maybe match a specific entity how about
that just to make it clear the some
issue here
okay space-related
you
oh my gosh
yeah these have you talked to the
curation team about these got what
Cerrito animals mammals to undertake
that oh yeah yeah because we need to be
able to write because you haven't got
those yet right because those aren't
entity types
these are entity types all no they're
not if I say entity reptile reptile
right I don't think that's gonna do
anything if I say entity list let's say
I say random entity reptile 10 I believe
it's gonna give me an error message so
that's something again you need to do an
ontology Yeah right we need to do those
and we know those we know all of those
we can we can deduce those and I think
this is something to talk to Tony and
Alan about I think it'd be nice to be
able to say random entity of animal
comma 10 in other words I think it needs
to be an a sub type so to speak
okay
you
now why are we not supporting drug here
and medical that's not right the drug
case of that that's really weird maybe
maybe we need what so it's a cipro is
that a is that a type of oh my gosh what
the heck is it maybe I'm wrong that
there what what say I'm a famous drug
lipitor how about that yes okay so that
became the chemical in that case that's
the generic name for that drug right
what sir we have candy corn 16 yeah
right
can we ask Sushma can we ask the
question why I thought we recognized I
mean we certainly seem to recognize drug
names but why do we not have an entity I
thought we had like a decade ago worked
with the u.s. pharmacopoeia farmer copia
right to UM get all the drug types yes
yeah I can ask them is there anything
like if you want was the woman way to
achieve example it's one they always
have a hard time to do because it you
know it was a woman with programming
language entity
yes I mean is there a way to do that in
the natural language input yes without
you know we thought that we talked about
doing that in connection with Wolfram
Alpha several years before it was
released having kind of a trick way to
do that and we ended up not doing it but
actually now we probably could use it
people would probably find it useful to
have a short term which is bla bla bla :
bla bla bla
that's a topic that's something to talk
to Alan and Michael about immigration
yeah I mean in other words to be able to
have an indicator that people could
reasonably type in for that um is that
the languages those are the languages we
have natural languages yeah we don't
know but some of these are ridiculous if
I might say so I mean some of these are
so obscure okay so if we have if we if
we say word list so there's again a
curation issue because I'm pretty sure
that that word list we probably have
some rolandic word list yeah you see
it's not even recognized as a type is
this even a language type do you know
it's mosby not necessarily based on the
top left top 60 or wikipedia a number of
pages free to be a page but that's
ridiculous Greenlandic i mean there is
an incredibly obscure language
look they let me have a list yeah what's
up no no no it's somebody somebody game
to a Kapadia or something stupid like
that right that though I don't
understand what Argon's are these that
did you train on these somehow it was my
first project in the company while
training these using values that I said
but Jean trilogy was just made taking
the first 60 or something Wikipedia
okay but but but but what we have now if
you do word translation of um you know
something like fish , all now we have a
lovely list of the languages in order
okay in order of frequency
you
it's been a while we have to do a new
version of the innovations to fail I I
hate to do it but I I feel like taking
out this obscure version of Greenlandic
I don't think it'll be in in here for
example what we landed people what's
that
there's a poor Greenlandic people well
I'm gonna I'm gonna find out something
here
maybe there's another name no we just
called romantic I'll do try did you try
there you go
oh well maybe I'm wrong there's a whole
5700 people no 57,000 people yes wow
it's almost the population of champagne
it's more than the population town I
live in there okay
um well I I don't know what you so these
are trained with with what data sets
these are this is puzzling which is what
does the needs of values that I said but
this is what language identify users
yeah
so language identify cannot generate a
language a language other than those so
if I say two language identify for
example whatever that is Mattia doesn't
seem to be non word yet
so it won't open eyes it it will say
something else something was say my
favorite yes
so this arguably should be redone yeah
Sushma do you know is that plausible
yeah I mean is that the Hindi is that
the right script
it's that language or different like I
don't know this you can read I mean like
can you read that
yeah I can do that so I had tired Hindi
the only thing that does not work is so
okay this is how it is there are there
is a concept of four walls and consonant
and when you add consonant to a woven it
changes so basically the first one the
first letter there is a combination of a
consonant and but if I try to type it
down it does not change that efficiently
so I don't know how you actually do that
I think it's what came out in the string
that's because of the string rendering
doesn't but okay all right so look
separate sub-project is absolute
language identified yeah different thing
mm-hmm because it actually works very
well for this stuff it has good
okay um all right I just want to okay so
these are quantitative elements see the
pity is that also are people people are
gonna want to tag with sentiment that's
gonna be another common thing
I think we should put that up at the top
well heck
I think languages and programming
languages should be down at the bottom
you
but some of this is ridiculously obscure
and how can we have a space in our name
here
look that there's no way these entities
that's weird is I'm not sure if this has
to be wrong whatever you did here this
is wrong
these are incorrect that we don't use
plus pluses and things like that
so something is wrong where this I mean
so we don't want spaces okay by the way
Sushma can you report another bug here
if you look at the autocomplete there
those things how did you construct these
strings like why is it was it documented
before
yes it's documented right here know this
yes but I believe in so if I look at
three plus plus for example right and I
look at I mean there'll be a standard
name right mm-hmm oh wow that's that's
really funky and that's probably stupid
also are using prototype odd must've
means a common name or something else I
don't even know what I'm using here how
can I tell let's see um system
information I suppose
okay so what you're saying here so so
look these are clearly goofed up so
these are got to be fixed these cannot
be the canonical names yeah whatever
they are you know if they're going to if
we're going to use those canonical names
have to agree with these make sense yeah
if they don't we're there and why there
um this is another bug for Allen there's
a cluster well how can you eat what that
how can you do it differently than C++
well you could say I I don't know how
we're gonna do it we could do it C++
like that for the canonical name we can
use a string but please talk to Alan
about it these are clearly wrong
okay like that one I'm quite certain
it's canonical name is not
yeah it's just that yeah why is C++
a bizarre canonical name I have no idea
well so this we can clearly fix right
now and we're gonna remove the space out
of area it's not just the space we've
got average agree with the canonical
names for the language entities for the
programming language entities
I think we should be more positive we
should start
but positive and go to negative maybe
I'm just sorry but but I think we should
go positive and negative neutral
[Music]
okay so where do we want to put this see
this feels to me like it's more goes
with the parts of speech I think it
should go up there
now whether we want to put topics how
important how good are our topics so no
dissent we had dissent I mean again if
there's a it's bit much is one of the
topic you can try it if you classify
Facebook topic in
does appear to Pikachu really works okay
well alright I think we've got a
reasonable first cut here okay so I
totally need to go imminently um is
there anything that we need to cover
specifically here okay so obviously
exactly one oh gosh so that's that's a
big question how many do we release
stuff in documentation because it is in
the
died anyway well I think you've got to
have a marker here after text case yes
that says um see we don't know how to do
that
no you don't know how to do that
um somebody says they asked for from how
many legs is the Hoey hyena have I'm
really surprised it doesn't know that
actually um there's been a lot of work
done actually rather recently on on
animal properties I'm really surprised
doesn't know that it's possible that the
production site doesn't know it yet but
I'm pretty sure that's something we know
um you ought to pass that query on to
Michael Sushma well how many legs does
our how you now have um isn't it lovely
that we go from you know well for those
who were here in the last hour of design
reviews we were talking about geometric
computation and winding numbers of
polygons and how we're reduced to how
many legs to Serena never mind okay so
here so yeah so you need to talk to
Brian about how to do that thing that
and I think what it should say what are
we going to have it's a we should say
let's just say text content types
okay that will be the phrase or
listening do we say listen interpreter
is a listing of interpreter types so
maybe listing of text content types
that's fine that sounds good to me and
then indentation like should we copy a
bit of the main ones or Oh be quiet
I would I would not do it I would just
say
well what do we do for something like
import
you
we're completely silent yeah I think
that's the right thing to do so I'm
gonna just just as an indication not
that it's real I'm gonna put this up
there
okay so this is actually very nice
functionality I have to say I think this
is really cool so if I were to do for
example um let me just try something so
if I were to say text cases of Wikipedia
data of cat comma date
okay oh you wish you'd sent me those
images let me take a look at those
cool now unfortunately some of these
things like tomorrow for example so if I
say date arrow interpretation
temperatures what do you mean it's gonna
be wrong if you say today in the text
and you just the interpretation it will
be always the day what they mean by
today well I mean the yeah that's kind
of funny right but it's gonna do that
that's kind of funny and ridiculous but
if a sheep is tomorrow and not today you
don't understand the difference no no
one of them was today one of them is
tomorrow right but the point is well how
do we handle that I I don't know it
depends what people want I think that's
good we separated really about you know
the string and interpretation yeah I
agree because the interpretation that
the problem is that this is a case okay
this is a case to mention to Nick
lariviere because the new temporal logic
stuff might handle this properly this is
an interesting case because its base
it's a tomorrow relative to a universe
of what the world is like which is
what's defined by the you know page for
cat get what I'm saying yeah strike
position a location is something that
Jerome just added and location and you
can put balls put string and
interpretation so you can see
because this is everything that can be
located somewhere right you could put it
on a map clear a finger doing an example
like that oh ouch
is this something you do it for by
unicode possibly some of that stuff
there are you handling for byte Unicode
correctly drum or are you just getting
whatever you get from the rest of the
system particularly for emoticons how
are you handling how does the how does
the text encoder for the neural net
handle for byte Unicode I think you
should check into that because I think
that could be broken at this point so
other thing there was not there before
the specific entity in the version you
tried last time it was just not not not
really yet so if you put that on so I
mean let's say dog for example or let's
put term and then I would say position
here or would I say position there if
you want another position
what is it saying 176 items what does
that mean is that sentences or what yes
I removed this contour know it so it was
bad cheese or but she's a sentence but I
removed all all the contours cool okay
so that's the number that's the places
the word dog is mentioned or something
that corresponds to dog is my response
to dog yeah so I guess jiggy with get it
as well I assume you know let's find out
or hate or dog should not get it but
that or I ate a hot dog should not get
it
you could try on no that looks good it's
dog-eat-dog yeah whatever I hate dogs I
really hope he doesn't get brilliant
that's very good
um but yet if I said food here
food is not good I had a problem to make
the training that I was fully out going
is a little weird but it's correct this
is very impressive Jerome it's very
impressive how does it speed compared to
any other ways to do this is it speed
respectable but sometimes interpreter
fix a lot of time are you batching
interpreter appropriately and now you
using you top of the caching properly
yes or the interpreter is caching and
I'm sending queries by batches let's
team ok um let me rewrite some of these
for speed there is a performance goal so
if you take something long you can do
personal goal goes to speed and I think
you just use classic spelling type thing
when using your network okay tagging
parts of speech now I assume I don't
know why we're capitalizing like that
switch one unless you know a standard
for that
I think we are capitalizing let me check
really good
running interpreter means interpreting
entities is that correct yeah I mean it
is off okay setting results yeah yeah
okay
okay so I'm proposing those I propose
that capitalization unless you have
reasons to think it shouldn't be that I
will check that and let your room know
but I think you should also add ellipsis
after the text because that is what we
do should be erotic all units so it's
grammatical analysis obviously okay okay
all right all right before mathematical
analysis
okay okay all right am i saving this
notebook does anybody care about
anything that's in here I don't think so
um and saying okay I think we are okay
what we do you know what is our thing is
that we need to gut these things and
basically remove all the specifics here
exactly and you can you can put in
things like entity like this right yeah
just have a thing that says you know
form or type and then something that
says entity right I mean I would say
roughly I would suggest doing this I
would say good least like two or three
and then get there all is there forms
forms
ported by M by text cases types of forms
types forms what Evers categories
include well entities and well I'm
saying just um quotes form um any
texts any text content type noun City
dot dot okay then
say
you
a specific entity then we say down here
this stuff right
you
you
which we have to merge in okay and then
pretty much everything here disappears
shall I just delete this so shy I think
I can just delete this because we are we
have it in CVS after all
go ahead
you
okay form supported by text cases
and should we document target device by
the way I don't remember what was the
conclusion of this discussion I don't
know
attend you know oh shoot oh no this is
horrible
commence that's maybe a sign that we
should be um okay that's a sign
Sushma I'm sorry you gotta clean this up
okay let's add also verbatim okay to
that list right and okay all right I
have got to go super late to here okay
all right
I think I don't had a question about
target do it yes if I get device we
document it and I think it was we
support it yard lots of machine learning
function so yes simply I mean you use a
bidding networks that we're gonna run
much faster on GPUs oh definitely
alright okay alright okay see y'all soon
thanks just let me just um um okay see
you later bye everyone
thanks